what percent of the fault do you assign
to Terry Sanderson
100 percent Gwyneth Paltrow smiled at
her attorneys after the verdict was read
Terry Sanderson claimed to have suffered
life-changing injuries when he claimed
Paltrow collided with him on a beginner
slope of a Park City Resort what amount
fairly compensates Gwyneth Paltrow for
economic damages one dollar outro's one
dollar award made it clear the case for
her was not about the money in a
statement after the verdict the Oscar
winner wrote I felt that acquiescing to
a false claim compromised my Integrity I
am pleased with the outcome as Paltrow
left the courtroom she touched
sanderson's shoulder and had a few words
for her accusers her exact words I wish
you well very kinder